how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talked about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU lately it's been kind of slow
considering the fact that Marvel Studios
has had to stop production on most of
their current projects that they have
going on for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe right now including all Disney
Plus shows and most of their movies but
fortunately for us they finished most of
the filming for the wann division series
and the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
series as well before they had to shut
down but now Marvel Studios is slowly
starting to open back up and pretty soon
they'll finish all production on the Wan
division series and the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier series as well and
there's also news of some eternals
reshoots as well which we'll talk about
in this video of course now one show
that's not completely done and still has
a lot of shooting left is the Loki
series this was a series that was in the
middle of filming when everything got
shut down but the good news is is that
they have the first season planned out
so when they resumed production things
should go pretty smoothly and recently I
stumbled upon a plot leak for the Loki
series and it seems really interesting
so I want to cover that today but this
leak involves a female version of Loki
which is already confirmed to appear in
the Loki series and involves a evil
version of Thor
but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a black
widow Funko pop all you got to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and leave a comment down
below so like with any and all plot
leaks there's no way of us really
knowing if this is real or not but like
with Avengers endgame and Avengers
infinity war some of the leaks that we
go over end up being true again there's
no real way of knowing but they're
always fun to go over so let's get into
it it begins by saying the Loki series
will begin in a room of interrogation
with the TVA the time of variants
Authority now to understand this plot
leak you're going to have to understand
who the time variants Authority are and
to put it very simplistically the TVA is
responsible for monitoring multiverses
and different timelines
if one universe begins to affect another
universe or one timeline begins to
affect another timeline it's their job
to stop that interference or completely
eliminate that universe or timeline
in order to save the others and of
course the TVA is already confirmed to
be in the Loki series we saw this in the
Super Bowl teaser that they gave us for
the Disney Plus shows and the one scene
that they showed us was with Loki in a
TVA jacket kind of looking like a prison
uniform so we do know that this part in
particular is true
Special Agent mark played by Owen Wilson
will be briefly introduced in Loki and
when they caught Loki he had the
tesseract in his hand and of course the
TVA took the tesseract from him while in
custody of the TVA they blamed the
entire events of the first Avengers film
on him in the events of the first
Avengers film they opened up a wormhole
and this wormhole led to other universes
and now it's up to the TVA to fix this
special agent markovin takes loki to
what is called a zero time zone and not
much information is really given about
this zero time zone but it seems to be a
place where there is no time and in this
zero time zone you can kind of go over
events that have already happened
slowing down time or reversing it and
Mark will apparently take Loki through
the events that happened in the Avengers
and show him how the wormhole to the
multiverse was created and they show him
how the rift created three different
universes the main universe with the
Avengers an alternate version of earth
and a universe in which they say there
was a quantum catastrophe
the TVA then explains how Loki is going
to help them fix this problem
Loki of course refuses and then he
attempts to break out look he breaks out
of his handcuffs tosses an agent to the
side and then sneaks past some guards
into the room where the tesseract is
being held look he runs to the tesseract
and he almost touches it but then time
suddenly starts to run backwards agent
mark ends up rolling back time and they
end up in the room of interrogation
where they started off and he tells Loki
that he has no choice mark leaves Loki
alone in the room and on the table there
are files of the deaths of Odin Frigga
and Loki at the hands of Fanus which
lead Loki to see that in a different
timeline
Thanos kills him next it shows a
character by the name mr. Mill's who
orders mark to proceed to the second
part of the plan next we enter a huge TV
a room with hundreds of TVA employees
that look almost the same they all look
like
now this is actually taken right from
the comics and the comics all of the
staff of the TV 8 looked exactly the
same and they did this because Marvel
was paying tribute to mark Gruen Wald
who was a Marvel writer and editor so
the fact that all of the staff of the
TVA is Mark as well makes a lot of sense
because they're still paying tribute to
him in the room we meet a character
called mobius in the comics mobius is a
frequent manager and is also a clone of
mark he's monitoring what is called The
Fault for information and it doesn't
really give any information about the
fault but we can assume it's something
that monitors different time lines in
different universes he ends up finding a
female version of Loki and he tells mark
to go check it out mark takes along with
him some soldiers and he goes to the
location
however while Morbius is examining it he
finds out that it's actually an
alternate earth and earth where Loki
actually killed Thor and now he's going
on to battle at New York we then cut
back to the room in which Loki is at
mark throws Loki a bracelet that says TV
a on it which all prisoners of the TVA
wear mark goes on to explain the
situation about the alternate universe
saying that it's in danger of being
destroyed the fault no longer stops and
they need to fix this on all three
different universes that the wormhole
opened mark tells Loki that they're
going to need to cheat time and he's
going to need the god of deception to do
it
Loki says gods you want to call another
meet and Mark says no someone better
than you we then go back to agent Mills
who was seemingly being controlled by an
unknown character we see him go into a
secret room inside of his office one
that has many different time devices
digital clocks mechanical clocks and our
glasses and we find out that he's able
to control time and universes through
these devices we then see mark Loki and
the rest of the TV a soldier's land on
the alternate earth it's pouring down
raining and we actually do have leaked
photos of this event and in the leaked
photos it does seem like Loki is going
on to help Marko of course is played by
Owen Wilson mark says that they're
heading to a site where something
strange is happening but he also
explains that they cannot run into the
Avengers so they must take the object
and leave before they run into him
Loki offers to play a time trick but
mark explains that it won't work here
and it's only possible in the zero time
zone they get to the location of the
event and they see female Loki but
turns out that she's actually not the
villain she's trying to stop the event
from happening here we see a black hole
that is absorbing and sucking in
everything around it it creates copies
of itself absorbs a black hole and then
burns out the black holes end up
creating ten different clones of the
female Loki mark yells that it's useless
now and he asked her to move away but
instead she throws mark and the rest of
his soldiers to the side Loki meanwhile
has done nothing and is just standing
there in the background and tell him and
Lady Loki lock eyes when this happens we
see a flash of bright light and here we
see some flashbacks of the origin of
female Loki here we see an alternate
version of Asgard that has an evil
version of Thor an adult whose face we
never see but from the few scenes it
becomes clear that Thor always dreamed
of the throne and in a struggle to
obtain the throne killed his father Odin
after several flashbacks of battles that
shows a dead body of Thor on the ground
and female Loki on the throne the room
is dark and it's empty we go back to
normal present time in which Loki and
the female Loki lie on the ground
unconscious
the TVA agents managed to delay the last
black hole so all of them can flee they
grab both Loki's and get on the capsule
and flee while on the capsule Marc
explains why the to Loki's past out he
says that alternate versions of
characters should never meet themselves
and he explains that some force out
there is trying to unite the universes
which would lead to the destruction of
all alternate versions of themselves
leaving only one and apparently this
effect has already started working we
then return back to the interrogation
room and Loki is staring at the female
version of Loki and fright mark then
enters the room looks at Loki and says I
need to show you something they go to a
different room where the flow of time is
represented by the projection of a river
kind of similar to what the ancient one
showed Bruce Banner and Avengers endgame
mark says that the fault
affected 586 events in the universe the
universe of the original Avengers the
events created a time machine and he
says that the main problem is not that
we need to govern something but rather
we actually need to repeat some of the
events that way the fault can be erased
and he tells Loki that he's going to
have to stay out of it but then he
brings up the period of the 1960s turns
to Loki and says
you need to kill someone and that's the
end of this plot leak now right away I
have to say that if this is indeed a
true plot leak it seems very very
exciting and something that I would
really love to see and the biggest thing
that I take away from this is the fact
that they said that universes are
starting to collide something is trying
to unite all of the universes and that
is exactly what takes place in Avengers
secret wars all of the different
multiverses end up colliding and we get
multiple versions of multiple different
characters all in one scene and as most
of us already know the next big Avengers
endgame level event should be Avengers
secret Wars battle world so it looks
like from the very beginning of phase 4
Marvel is going to set up the events
that are eventually going to lead to the
final battle and Avengers secret Wars
which no surprise here this is exactly
what Marvel does they set up Thanos
since the very first Avengers movie and
then several several years down the road
we finally got Avengers infinity war and
Avengers end game so if this all ends up
being true we're in for some really
exciting things and phase four and the
rest of the phases and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so things are getting
really exciting a lot of production on a
bunch of different projects are starting
up again soon salma hayek recently
posted on her Instagram that she's
getting ready for reshoots for the
Eternals so things are getting moving
again so let me know what you think
about this plot leak in the comments
down below and don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all things relating to the
MCU for live updates you can follow me
on Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof